what were you guys doing in
daytona weren't you guys filming some
sort of like crazy i was in jacksonville
jackson i was in jacksonville working on
a bigger project uh that i
can't really talk about and i want to
tell
[Applause]
uh i filmed uh i i may or may not have
filmed
um a part of something that may become a
documentary
later down the road and that's really i
can that's really all i can say
so so you uh they film something that
is being pitched to big networks major
networks yeah
cool yeah yeah that's pretty exciting
all i know is i saw that picture from
matt cox of you wearing a robe
like smoking a cigar it was ridiculous
they had me in a mansion
uh and you know it's just giant [ __ ]
gaudy mansion and they rent it out
it was airbnb yeah it ran out i was like
[ __ ] it was expensive um
yeah you know they'd be in a cigar and a
robe coming downstairs and you know
you know all kinds of different scenes
they listen i've seen some of the stuff
they cut
they made me look way [ __ ] cooler
than i am you know what i mean they made
me look like pablo escobar or somebody
like that you know
i just just the cinematography and like
the way they captured the light and just
the music and the way they're doing
everything it's
it's gonna be [ __ ] cool and it's
gonna sell how many days were you there
filming
five days five days you know i filmed
every day
and how much can they possibly film in
five days i'm sure like many days of it
was just
b-roll and like cinematic like looks
type stuff well we would basically we
would film during the day we would just
film like you know interview [ __ ] during
the day or you know other things that we
were doing like
for the story and then like at night
when we wrap up the day shooting we'd
film like b-roll [ __ ] you know like
cinematic out in the public republic or
whatever
yeah it was cool yeah it's so weird it's
a weird thing how like
now big tv networks and production
companies that sell [ __ ] to tv networks
all they're doing is just scouring the
internet for like popular podcasts
yeah to try to find content yeah listen
i get i got
uh approached by two different people
from vice tv trying to [ __ ]
do something with me they wanted they
had some kind of series that they were
doing with people who
um did major like crimes when they were
younger and then turned their life
around or some [ __ ] you probably maybe
have seen a couple episodes i think they
had one with a dude who was like um
i apparently sold millions of dollars
worth of cocaine or something like that
in new york when he was a kid and they
had some other dude on there um
i don't remember his story but i think i
think that's the series that they wanted
me for and it's like i can't even
i can't do anything with anybody else oh
because that company that you shot the
pilot with they got you under some sort
of exclusivity
exclusivity agreement and it just
wouldn't be right at the end of the day
it wouldn't be right because i think i
i think it would hurt me more than it
would help how long did they have you
locked up in that agreement for
um i do you know we don't i
think six months six months it's not bad
yeah yeah over a year would
not be good no because they can't sell
it in six if they can sell it in six
months that's great but yeah it goes
longer than that
it's gonna sell it's gonna sell right
away it's not even gonna take six months
have they even started pitching it yet
uh i'm not sure where they're at in the
pro you know what i'm hands off on this
thing like i don't call them and like
what's going on what are you guys doing
you know what i mean like i'm just like
dude you guys do your thing you know
what i mean like i'm just gonna sit back
and
call me when it's time to collect the
check check me out when you're ready you
know what i mean when it's time for me
to [ __ ] make a deposit into my chase
account then give me a call
yeah the other other i mean because i
can't control anything i have no
creative say so and anything like that
and it's just like
i got so much other [ __ ] going on in my
life that i just yeah i just leave it
alone dude i let them people just do
their [ __ ] thing and i think they
kind of like that anyway you know yeah
yeah yeah it's a weird thing what did
you think about the whole process
of like those guys like bringing in all
those cameras setting up all that stuff
like like orchestrating everything to
make it look like
it's a lot of [ __ ] work right i got i
got to peek behind the curtain man you
know and i got to kind of see how the
whole machine works
you know and that's cool because you
watch the behind the scenes [ __ ]
sometimes you know what i mean when you
do
you know like hbo behind the scenes and
all that [ __ ] but it doesn't it doesn't
do any justice when you're there
you know what i mean you got guys
running cable running cables and
changing lights around and you know
putting up light boxes and you know like
[ __ ] chat
it's just the whole thing and then you
got the sound guys with the
yeah it's cool man it's cool i could get
used to that man i'm the talent yeah
right
so i don't have to do no work yeah
you're good you know what i mean you
want a soda you [ __ ] you're hungry
you know what i mean i'm just laying
back [ __ ] in between scenes [ __ ]
just you know taking a nap or whatever
[ __ ]
you know and then when they say [ __ ]
roll camera i'm then i gotta jump to it
you know what i mean and that's
that's my part i play in it you know
what i mean so so how many
vice actually emailed you and try to get
you to do something i had two different
uh i had
one uh lady reached out who said she was
with vice but really she was with an
independent production company that i
think
works for vice vice contractor yeah and
then actual vice tv
actually because i ignored her and i
just didn't respond to her actual vice
tv reached out after that
and and contacted me and you know i was
i told him i was like listen
right now i can't i can't do anything i
can't do any movies or tv podcasts are
fine
as long as i you know don't open the can
of worms and you know
you know what i mean like yeah um yeah i
can't do any tv or movies or anything
for right now but i was like in the
future it doesn't mean i can't in the
future i'm just i'm like i'm i'm
contractually obligated right now as of
right now i can't yeah i can't do
anything
like vice i'm sure it'll pay me a couple
grand to go wherever and shoot but it's
just like
that's peanuts compared to what i got
coming the big thing yeah so i don't
want to [ __ ] this up with you know what
i mean yeah
i know they did something with matt cox
but i don't know if i ever saw it i
don't know if it ever came out
they did yeah i think they did uh matt
did something with them i don't know
advice yeah i never i don't know what it
was he said they flew him out and paid
him like [ __ ]
well i think they shot it like in tampa
right i thought he said miami
was it miami yeah we flew him down to
miami yeah some mansion and [ __ ]
yeah and they just interviewed him they
just sat him on a stool and [ __ ]
interviewed him and
so if you did some sort of if somebody
let's just say
some big compass some big network bought
this
project that you guys shot
what would it be like would it be like a
serialized documentary would it be
just a one-shot like two-hour film and
see that's the thing that
right now we just don't know you know
what the format will be yeah because
it's like
say they take it to fx fx might want to
make it into a series
right you know what i'm saying or say
they take it to hulu and hulu just wants
to shoot it as a dock
right you know what i mean which it's
cool because that doc could lead to a
series
or could lead to a feature-length film
you know what i mean or they could take
it to
like you know try to attach like a big
name to it and take it to like a like a
big production company
and they could be like [ __ ] let's
just run with this thing and make it a
feature film right
you know so all like all that shit's up
in the air right now which is [ __ ]
exciting that
that's all this is even an option for me
you know what i mean like i think even
more
even a more interesting spin-off would
just be you selling
1000 consultations on instagram
one of those phone calls yeah listen i
gotta get my money man i gotta get this
live we get people to call in live that
would have been amazing
i gotta get my money you know what i
mean at the end of the day it's
there's something there well people i
think people are attracted to that kind
of story
like people like you that come from the
gutter from the the ugly corner
yeah and uh you come up and and you're
able to go through everything you went
through and then there's something also
about
like scams people who have committed
scams or frauds
it's the zeitgeist of our time right now
it's it's
all things current like whatever this
little atmosphere we're living in with
the fraud and the scams it's been
um how do i want to say
it's it's it's like hollywood now like
before it was like just like an
underground
thing that only like a select few people
like if you were a nerd or you were into
fraud you knew about it now it's like
[ __ ] who aren't even doing
fraud or scams are saying they're
scammers and fraudsters just you know
what i mean to be part to be part of
something
like it's so [ __ ] crazy like these
kids that reach out to me on instagram
you should see their instagrams like
they're taking pictures of all this
money and all this [ __ ]
and then like i'll have a conversation
with them and it immediately i know they
don't know [ __ ]
they know absolutely dick you know what
i mean they're just [ __ ] trying to be
cool
like it's it's cool to say you're a
scammer now you know what i mean all the
rappers are talking about it and then
you got this guy [ __ ] ban man cabo
whoever the [ __ ] he is i haven't watched
any of his videos everybody's telling me
watch band man kevo man reach out i'm
like listen man band man kevin
apparently okay this is what i know
about him i haven't researched i've
never read anything about him i've never
watched i've watched
clips and heard him talk a little bit
but it's like apparently he was some
rapper
and he got caught up doing check scams
for like
less than a million dollars it wasn't
even that much money and he went to
prison and now he got out
and apparently he charges [ __ ]
150
for [ __ ] face times and he's got he's
got his own youtube channel where he
tries to teach people about like
fraud and [ __ ] like cpns and all the
[ __ ] that's going to send people to
prison immediately
like he's he's like the go-to guy for
scams and frauds now in like the hip-hop
community you know what i mean like he's
whatever man you know what i mean like
[ __ ] whatever dude like but that i'm
just saying like that's just how absurd
all of this has become
yeah you know what i mean and i don't
want to be that guy i don't want to be
that guy on my youtube channel trying to
teach people how to do fraud and
doing the whole credit card thing and
all that [ __ ] i just don't want to be
that guy
yeah i want to be the guy making people
helping people make better decisions
you know what i mean i want to keep
people out of prison yeah how are you
going to do that
well i mean i just feel like i have such
a vast amount of life experience to draw
from that i mean i can
i can give good advice you know what i
mean and i i'm a straight shooter
i don't candy coat anything you know
what i mean i'm quick to tell somebody
they're full of [ __ ]
or or what you're doing with your life
is [ __ ] meaningless and you need to
do something else if you want to make
changes
you know what i mean like i just keep it
real with people like i make videos
about like being successful and like
what i feel it takes to be successful
you know what i mean it starts when you
wake up in the morning you wake up you
[ __ ] eat the same breakfast you make
your bed you have a plan for the day you
know what i mean and i just break it all
down like this is what you need to do to
be successful
you know what i mean you need to cut all
the [ __ ] people out of your life you
need to quit [ __ ]
you need to cut all the things out of
your life that are [ __ ]
causing you any kind of discomfort or
harm you know what i mean
just [ __ ] like that you know like my
guide to success so i make videos like
that like motivational type stuff
exactly that's what i'm on dude just
straight motivational like you know what
i mean all positivity
you know